hello everybody and welcome to part 17
of let's play from dust alright I
restarted the village because as you saw
in part 16 it didn't go so well so I had
an idea I'm gonna go straight to this
one that gives me the power to evaporate
because I noticed the volcano it only
spills lava down this way which is bad
and the water is a problem if I can't
get to here which is also bad I'll come
back and get umm amplified breath later
but right now I know I absolutely know I
need to get rid of this water somehow
and that way I can go straight to
infinite earth and that can help me out
so oh you guys are so slow well my voice
is finally better so I'm hoping to ruin
it again by screaming as loud as I can
all the time alright alright
oh-oh-oh volcano I'll bring it on I'm
ready for you Oh totally cock-blocked me
last time but whatever just a little
more protection I'm gonna just deposit a
little bit on the other side so it flows
the other way okay there goes yes
see that's right
um yeah if I couldn't control that rain
somehow this water would have just built
up it's a bowl I can't destroy the edges
so it would have killed everyone Oh No
did did you just oh come on people it's
not hard not hard just go just go just
go go go go go quickly quickly quicker
quicker Lee there you go
so smart you are not alright there we go
okay I got that let me build up this
bridge a bit more because I do not want
these people to die believe it or not I
actually don't want all my people to die
horrible deaths okay evaporate and
that'll evaporate the whole place and I
can get to that one infinite earth oh
yeah I'm so smart
alright but this is still gonna be a
problem because now I don't even know
how I can get to that maybe I can build
a volcano up enough so that it kind of
blocks out everything but no this is
bubbling out like crazy I don't even
know how that's gonna happen um maybe I
could just get out of here lava I see my
people are over there maybe the other
people can just go here can they the
right there yes
please do you lazy bums get there before
that becomes a problem once that goes
hopefully hopefully I can get it sort of
going I'm gonna try to make a river here
or a faux riverbed so that it flows not
towards anything important to sort out
kinda make a little divot here I know
I'm asking for a lot but maybe maybe I
can keep my people from dying it's
always a hope hope II hope hope
okay that's actually looking a lot
better a lot better okay and now I get
the people go here if it breath oh I
think I'm actually gonna do it okay that
village is done they'll send an envoy
get that clean up here Oh who's the best
oh look at me oh ho I'm the greatest I
want to finish this in record time yeah
no no lava stop build up cool down cool
your head Sean yeah that's right that's
right you didn't want to mess with me
okay now people are going to that
village um all repopulate get it oh I
need more peeps need more peeps okay yep
okay the breath that's cool ah that's
getting a little too close ah my breath
get out of here lava a little too close
for comfort I need to build another
river okay just sorta yep nope nope nope
stop yeah there you go
there you go that's what happens when
you play nice
oh oh oh oh no oh no oh no what the hell
what the hell e hell hell
oh no no no no no no why why did it why
did that happen
oh no that is horrible why why oh my
goodness oh my goodness oh my goodness
that is horrifying okay I need to build
up a wall around here maybe maybe just
sort of stop people from dying that
would be nice I don't I don't want my
people to die okay alright
sort of got it get the Lava out of there
oh man that is horrifying Oh
get out of there don't close them off
don't close them off no get out of here
oh okay that's what the rain controls oh
those scary oh I feel so bad how people
are dying people are done white wire why
aren't they passing on the secrets of
black lava baklava oh no oh no
give him the secrets I'll give him oh
damn Oh poop oh damn Oh No
okay they have the secret Oh criminy
Christmas is horrifying
okay block Oh
oh my goodness gimme I'll get away dirt
I don't want you right now oh oh oh my
god oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my goodness this is this is
the worst this is the worst I had this
under control
poor why why build villages inside a
volcano this is literally inside a
volcano holy crap man holy crap holy
this is I don't think I can recover from
this they're trying to build their but
it's just gonna burn right up yeah
good good job there oh man
Oh what can I do I can't do anything
this is over this game's over man
all right okay that sucked all right
[ __ ] it I'll just restart sorry guys
apparently I suck coz huh I should have
known the entire place was gonna fill up
with lava I mean that was obvious to
everyone I'm guessing the water needs to
stay there at least for a little bit
because the water at least is gonna
control some of it
so I can't evaporate right away which
means I don't need to go to the
evaporate right away nah man Messala
DCPI akira Cici kita actually what I
probably should have done is used
infinite earth more early and then get
the anti position are oh yeah I can
position the village's duh-doy okay just
because that one's the first one I can
get that right away then send one to get
this and then go get that this one and
then populate that one and move it
inland oh man in fact I should move this
one but not right away okay that that go
kay you're ready you're ready ready once
you populate it almost there
are you there come on now okay I heard
the whoo
assume that no don't what are you doing
ah hey you i hate you all
you're so stupid you were ah I'm gonna
I'm gonna kill someone no no stop it
yeah no water get out of here no no no
no no no
[ __ ] right off no stop pouring that way
or this way this way okay
village is done move on get this thing
and go go go buddies go oh no this was a
problem that's why I need the evaporate
oh that's why I need the evaporate
bok-bok-bok akka dr. cooky oh that's bad
oh I screwed up again I had it right the
first time ah great scrub scrub you know
it's great screw it man people were
telling me that these last two levels
we're gonna be a [ __ ] and a half but
[ __ ] aw man ah all right I'm gonna lose
my voice again just screaming in rage
ah all right let's go about this the
badass way gone movements come on come
on
Oh bring it on Oh bring it on oh yeah
I'm so ready
go go go go go go go go go go
you're gonna get it go go go go yeah
yeah yeah super spam all right that's
going there all right okay as soon as
they get there the lavas gonna be stupid
but it's gonna be fine
ah then I go immediately here because
peeps are right there
can grab that grab that get that move
that in to right here-ish so that the
lava outside doesn't completely destroy
everything and then move peeps here as
soon as that's populated okay I got this
I got this I got this
okay all right I'm ready is my next move
maybe kill to make the lava okay okay
okay all right
okay there's the water but that's okay
because I got the water under control
okay blocking that off so nothing slows
down my guys all right and then gonna
just create a little river here riverbed
riverbed uh-huh uh-huh and then make
that flow another way not into where I
need to be cuz we're so smart so smart
so smart
oh no my guys are flooding over there
but they're gonna be okay they survived
last time they can survive this time oh
okay all right ready ready ready ready
what's going on
why the screaming ah come on No oh I
hate this I hate this so much
ah ah did everyone die everyone died
Oh fantastic fine fine ah okay okay
that's fine
this games want to be that way it could
be that way all right uh all right
anyway
thanks guys so much for watching and
watching me rage I will see you guys in
part 18 of from dust where I will kick
this Maps ass bye bye